improviseur a été menacé de mort par le
père d'une lycéenne qui portait la Bahia
ça s'est passé jeudi 7 septembre au
lycée Ambroise Brugière à
Clermont-Ferrand dans la matinée une
lycéenne s'est vu refuser l'accès à son
établissement scolaire car elle portait
une habaya conformément en directives
nationales mais quand son père a été
informé de la situation il a appelé le
lycée et a proféré des menaces de mort
envers proviseur l'éducation nationale a
immédiatement déposé plainte et l'homme
a été interpellé et placé en garde à vue
l'interdiction de cette robe longue
couvrante a été annoncée par le ministre
de l'éducation nationale pour la rentrée
2023 puis validé ce jeudi par le Conseil
d'État il a en effet estimé que le port
à l'école de la Bahia ou du camis son
équivalent masculin s'inscrivait dans
une logique d'affirmation religieuse la
semaine dernière le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a adressé un
télégramme à tous les préfets il a
demandé à ce que si des proviseurs
étaient victimes de menaces ou
d'agressions en lien avec le port de la
Baya il bénéficie sans délai de
l'assistance des forces de l'ordre selon
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel Attal 298 élèves se sont
présentés vêtus d'une à Baya et 67
jeunes filles ont refusé de se conformer
à la règle ces comportements
concerneraient moins d'une centaine
d'établissements en France
[Musique]